what do you do when you launch something
and it goes terrible one is worse than
zero right it's better like if nobody
shows up because then you don't have to
do anything right is there anybody who
you're afraid of disappointing and
obviously we're afraid of disappointing
the one person who paid for the thing
because we need to give them value are
we afraid that like Seneca is going to
be upset that we didn't get more people
you make a list of anybody who you're
afraid of like the judgments and then we
attack the list and people know your
heart and your care and your the
intention behind this they're pretty
forgiving like if you make a mistake and
you own up to it and you try to make it
better it often leads to just amazing
relationships as well it definitely can
work for sure workshops work advertising
work it works you just didn't execute it
great cool expect to suck and not
execute great at the beginning it's fine
if you're perfect at the beginning then
it's actually not inspiring other people
and that's the story of almost every
entrepreneurs like they struggled and
they failed and they sucked at the
beginning and they just kept going I
wish I was smart enough to think about
that when I was first getting started
what do you do when you launch something
and it goes terribly what do you mean it
goes terrible
you only do lives for my company and I
have normally between like 30 and 50
people and we don't really do like it's
organic just you know people that and
I've been doing this since once like
probably two or three months ago once
um Sans suggested you should go live
every week and I started doing it and it
has been working well more appointments
really nicely so I started thinking okay
let's do something else something
different so we should do a workshop a
paid Workshop you have people who's only
interested in actually you know um doing
the the registration in the programs we
have and I uh said well we should do
like a very low fee just to have the
commitment and and kind of like to test
the market which is something that we
have also took uh in these meetings so I
did that and um and I was uh you know I
had a conversation with one of the
colleges here in in Canada with Seneca
College which is fairly big and they
even give us they even gave us some
budget to do the you know the the
promotion and all so we use the budget
and everything so we had people asking
we had people you know lots of likes
lots of cards and all that but it's a
little bit embarrassing but just one
actually payment came through just one
okay this one and it's today okay and
it's coming up or or it hasn't happened
yet
it's today yeah today at 7 p.m oh good I
so so listen this is great like one is
worse than zero right it's better like
if nobody shows up because then you
don't have to do anything right but one
person shows up and then it's like one
person
um
you lean into it is there anybody who
you're afraid of disappointing right
obviously we're afraid of disappointing
the one person who paid for the thing
because we we need to give them value
are we afraid that like Santa's gonna be
upset that we didn't get more people or
is there anybody is there anybody
besides the one person that you're
afraid of disappointing yeah my the rest
of directors in the in the farm were not
that happy
in the sense that you know I I kind of
like uh
promoted these and instead of doing what
we regularly do and you know they were
not that happy but at the end it's not
the end of the world the worst part
would be and those the person who paid
but it's just one so I don't have a
problem I'll have the consultation with
him
um you know a free consultation and that
will pay whatever he paid because it was
just ten dollars it was just very a very
little fee just to get those who are
really interested I don't think it's
gonna be a good idea even if we have
couple more registrations I don't think
it's a good idea to do the workshop
Maybe
I don't know if it's better just to meet
with them one-on-one or maybe should I
go under the workshop and kind of like
swallow the the the the the the bad
moments like with three people there and
of course I had to explain I have to
explain Seneca College that this didn't
work the market the market I work with
it's very
tough in that sense of pain so and this
was a test yeah so it didn't work it's
kind of like I mean that moment that
what should I do now
right you you make a list of anybody who
you're afraid of like the judgments and
then we attack the list so if it's your
if your uh directors at your firm are
upset you can you can handle that like
you know how to talk to them it's a test
guys we need to test we can't just keep
doing the same thing and instead of me
spending my time doing personal stuff
I'm spending time on this like this is
this is an attempt right so we can we
can handle them Seneca if you're worried
that you spent their money and it didn't
get a result well what else could we do
to deliver value for them build the
relationship right it's just like
there's lots of things that you could do
that either are outside of this one
this one advertising
you know mistake air quotes uh that you
can just bring value to that
relationship like if I went and I
totally bombed on uh Brendan wants me to
speak at his event next month right if I
go upstage and like forget what I'm
gonna say and just totally bomb cool I
can make it up to him like if something
happened and I sucked on stage I could
make it up I would find a way to make it
up to bring incredible value to him and
his team so you can make it up to the
people of Seneca
um so the one person you just go and
crush and give them tons of value right
I mean you can even lean into it it's
like hey this was a test for us
you're the you're the person who took
action I love you like let's go and and
you just again you focus on who you have
instead of who you don't if I look at
this like you know how many people do we
have live here why if it was one person
it was you me and Zayn we would still do
this and we'd have a good time helping
we've got I don't know 12 people if it
was a hundred people like we'd still
it doesn't like you can make the
decision whether you keep going or not
but you can you can bring tons of value
to that one person so that helps
alleviate everything because you can you
know you can make it up to everybody you
know you can bring value to everybody
and nobody's going to be pissed at you
after today right cool
the next thing I pay attention to is did
you love the thing like my first
speaking gig in Toronto was that the
YMCA for free and three people showed up
after I promoted it and they promoted it
for free in a giant room I show up with
this giant like Auditorium and there's
three people who are there like oh my
gosh what is this I feel like the
biggest failure of all time
um and I decided Well I already did my
presentation like I already know I
already prepared so much and I was so
nervous because it was one of my first
presentations and um
I just went and did it and it was
amazing
you know it's like I have to I have to
keep going and logically it doesn't make
any sense like if if I promoted it and
nobody showed up and the YMCA promoted
to their members and nobody like nobody
three people showed up how am I ever
gonna make this this is not a business
this is stupid
but I loved it
and so I kept doing it and I found a way
right so more important than did this
work do workshops work absolutely so
something in the in the in the mechanics
of it didn't work something in the
marketing and promotion of it didn't
work something in the copy didn't work
something on the in the video didn't
work or the advertising was spent
incorrectly like there's many things
that probably didn't work
that doesn't mean that the project is
dead because workshops work
it's more you do it with this one person
and you see do did I love this
and if you love helping them then you
have one now and you try to fix the
marketing for the next time and then you
have three or five or seven or ten or
Twenty or like it just keeps building
but the the test isn't did it work or
not because nothing works the first time
like the the chances of something
working the first time I was talking to
the president of Shopify right and you
guys know Shopify you can build your
website and so so
he was saying that all of the um if you
combine all the Shopify stores together
and at Canada's one store they'd be the
second largest store in the world after
Amazon crazy
um and what he said was almost everybody
who's had success on Shopify if you look
at the people who like sold a million
dollars plus through Shopify
it was like their third or fourth store
on Shopify like they had tried Shopify
before and it didn't work out didn't
work out right so like but kept going
started another store where the biggest
mistake is starting one store it doesn't
work oh I guess it's not for me and then
you quit and that's the story of almost
every entrepreneurs like they struggled
and they failed and they sucked at the
beginning and they just kept going so it
definitely can work
for sure workshops work advertising work
it works you just didn't execute it
great
cool
expect to suck and not execute grade at
the beginning is fine you go and deliver
for this person did you love it was it
fun could you imagine 5 10 100 people
there and it being fun yes then you keep
going
um no then you stop you know
so but that's much more of a heart
decision because your your head can
figure it out with enough repetition
does that help I went a little I went on
a little speech there but I got excited
it's so exciting because like I can I
can now say you know I felt like the
Biggest Loser of all time when I was at
the YMCA doing that event like I felt
like I wanted to go and hide like I
can't believe I'm such a failure this is
ridiculous plus I pinned my whole career
now like this is what I'm gonna do for
the rest of my life I'm so excited like
oh I can't do this like this is not
gonna work so it's this giant failure
moment
um but I'm so excited that that happened
because now I can share that story right
people will be inspired in in five years
ten years by your success they can say
guys when I started
I got one person it was 10 bucks and
only one person showed up the crate I
felt like the biggest loser
and but I kept going and here's what
happened right
um if you're perfect at the beginning
then it's actually not inspiring other
people
so just going like just give love to
this person go crush it for them
and then see if you liked it and if you
loved it then then keep doing it and if
not you move on to something else
yes I'll have an inspiring speech after
tonight there you go I love it and
listen whenever I'm afraid to do
something
um that'll be one of the things because
I'm I'm afraid of disappointing people
so when I'm afraid of doing something I
will ask myself like can I make it up if
I screw this up can I make it up to
people
you know and the answer is like I can
always find a way to make it up to
people so cool let's do it like when my
tour got canceled
I was my 20
20 tour when did I break my neck it's 20
20. uh 2019 I broke my neck we did it so
2020 I was doing another tour and we had
sold tickets Across America like 22
cities we were promoting spending money
advertising pitching
selling tickets to and I'm I'm about to
go across the border and speak in
wherever like Buffalo or whatever my
first speaking gig and I get denied at
the border and it shuts down the whole
the whole trip
and so now we have to
it's like all these people who bought
tickets to come see me and now I can't
do any of them because I got stopped at
the border and so like panic mode right
away like oh my gosh this is the most
terrible thing of all time I feel bad
for the two people who my camera guy and
my driver who was Jeremy at the time
were coming along and they got stopped
they playing for this
um they're like okay I can make it up to
Jeremy my first like I can make it up to
Jeremy and Ray who are coming with me
I'm going to take him to the to The Keg
which is a kind of fancy Steakhouse here
in Canada and just tell them get
whatever you want just it's on me by the
fanciest steak whatever you want it's on
me because I feel guilty for like you
committed three months of your life to
come with me and now it's all over
and they were fine and I told them I
felt guilty like no no this is great no
worries
and then it's all the people who bought
tickets to my event like I can make it
up to them can I make it up to them yes
like a personal message to everybody
obviously refund but like a refund for
me Isn't Enough so it's a personal
message to everybody I think we even
offered like a call
like a call with me if if they have
bought the ticket within a certain
amount of time or something
um so like you can always make it up to
people and people know your heart and
your care and your like the intention
behind this
they're they're pretty forgiving like if
you make a mistake and you own up to it
and you try to make it better it often
leads to just amazing relationships as
well honestly one of my biggest regrets
in thinking about this like get save the
name email phone number contact
information of this one person
so that in five years or ten years we
can like do an IG live with them or
something he's like you were the one
person only one verse like I don't know
who the three people were who that would
be the best thing of all time like who
are the three people who came to my
first thing being able to have them on
now
and say you were there at the YMCA right
I wish I had kind of kept in touch
um so yeah if you had their contact info
that could be a cool now we're turning
into something much bigger but um yeah I
even have his credit card information
well there you go
build a relationship honestly like
follow them on social if they have it
like build like if you love doing it and
it becomes something man that first
person to be able to say only one person
showed up and we're still in touch and
here's what they're doing and and show
the success that you're able to help
them with
yeah I wish I I wish I was smart enough
to think about that when I was first
getting started with those three people
I want to know I don't remember them I
was so nervous and so scared and so
feeling like a loser I can't even see
their faces the three people who showed
up so
um yeah that'd be pretty cool thank you
yeah yeah I think and what you helped me
help me bring value to each of the parts
involved because I'm not afraid of you
know falling down and hit the floor
right you know it had happened before
and I know that I can you know uh stand
up again I know that so yeah it was kind
of like very disappointing to to to
listen that there was just one
registration yeah but I can't I can
survive that but yes I was concerned
about all the all the other parties you
know that are involved in this but I
think that I can made up for them and
yeah I'll definitely I'll definitely
find a way to and you gave me with the
process of thinking that so thank you
thank you so much there we go well
that's why Community is so important
I came back to the the community after
um basically from covid joining a firm
um but kind of going through these
iterations of doing everything that you
inspire and advised me to do but
unfortunately the environment's a little
uh super intense and very stressful and
kind of toxic but I keep putting my head
down to pursue it at the goal of being
uh of being a partner so at the end of
last year because the projections didn't
come true uh based on what I was brought
under the Compensation Plan
um basically I was incentivized that
there would be a partnership agreement
this year and so Tuesday we went to
lunch finally after monthly talks with
the CEO from July to now and uh did not
come out what was I expecting and what I
was enticed for this whole time and so
now I'm trying to keep my head down and
stay focused and keep the positive North
light but I feel very Rocky in my career
career again versus having this goal of
growing with people and having a bigger
impact than doing everything on my own
and so the question is
how to figure that out so I've had a
couple talks with mentors around this
and I know talked about Zan and some of
the others in the community and it's
about building a brand Do Your Own Thing
what I realized for myself is I'm a very
extroverted person I'm complimented
better when I'm in a component of a team
versus being a solopreneur
um I'm you know I'm good at strategy put
it you know impacting others or
communicating marketing
Investments and like wealth building but
now it's to figure out
where do I go to have that larger impact
and do what you said which is have that
North Star that continues to be that and
I think one of the challenges from covet
is I had ownership of my trajectory is
part of a business for our partners and
businesses now I don't have ownership
over my income and financial abundance
and trajectory and that's been
constraining me because I'm not doing as
well as I was prior to covet
sure I mean you just don't have
ownership of your trajectory inside this
company
but you still have ownership of your
trajectory for where you could go
correct
and that's and that is a important
mental distinction for you as well that
it's not over and you're not screwed for
life and you're not
permanently stuck and it doesn't mean
you have to go quit this job right now
and go without a parachute you know into
the Brave New World you know you don't
want to start a company at least not yet
awesome and what's great is you know
kind of what you want to do like having
that North Star you don't you don't need
to be stuck on the how
you know you want to have a bigger
impact you know you want to have
ownership you know you want to serve
more you know you want to work with a
team you know you want to have a boss
that supports you mentors you guides you
and and values you great
how all that happens you don't have to
you like you'll never figure out those
steps from where you are right now
and that's okay why is that because the
way that my brain is wired is to think
about the Tactical and I hear you say
that all the time but I don't understand
it because I think about reverse
engineering yeah and there's nothing
wrong and listen I'm the same way like
gold oriented what's the plan how how
how let's go
I love that that's the best the problem
is there's too many variables that you
don't understand
so your plan right now is based off of
what you currently know and you don't
know enough so your plan has a million
holes in it
so it doesn't mean don't have a plan
but recognize that your plan is very
basic compared to what you're going to
make
and this is why there's a problem or at
least I have a problem I think with five
or ten year goals
because you just don't know like go back
to meet from 10 years ago whatever plan
like you've been goal-oriented and plan
oriented you know most of your adult
life probably so if you go back look at
you from five years ago or ten years ago
you know sameed in in 2015 making his
plan for 2022. you're not here
because 2015 samit has just different
information
he doesn't know what he knows now
and so there's a it's an audacity to
then think well I can I know where I'm
going to be in the next five years or
seven years or what my plan is going to
be so you make your best guess at a plan
like don't let that be so overwhelming
that you do nothing because that's the
worst
okay your your plan is to
start talking to a lot of people until
you create an opportunity
do you think there's any uh necessary
steps I think this was the so I was in
in the Big Four County in New York City
and I've tried to stay within the
umbrella of real estate but I realize I
don't need to always stay to that but do
you think that there's unnecessary focus
of staying in a in a I don't know it's a
Continuum of your skill set development
so that you're not jumping from one
thing for two to three years and then
another thing for another three years I
I think about it as momentum
um but I think that's also what prevents
me from going to other areas yeah
similarly so this is like the very first
question that's a hard question
you're trying to answer a heart question
with your head yeah the head would be
yeah staying the same thing get more
experience go keep learning get better
improve build more contact stay in real
estate that's logically what you should
do yeah the problem is if your heart's
not into it you're not going to win so
if you're going to be going off and
learning some new skill because that's
what's in your heart to go off and do it
may it may be it may feel like a step
back but it ends up creating a thousand
steps forward
because if you just stay in real estate
what you're going to do if it's not at
you in your heart you're going to learn
to hate it more and more and more and
more and more every day
and it's the right strategy head wise
for who you are right now and what you
know but it's not what you actually want
to become
now it doesn't mean you go off and dump
it all and become a vegan Chef I don't
know or maybe it is
you know that's your thing but you have
a it'll be a temporary setback as you go
and learn that thing and it doesn't
sound like you're like an all-in kind of
guy you want to make your steps to make
progress so I would explore I think the
best thing you can do right now is you
have your intention which is awesome
now you go explore
you go explore you start talking to
people you start talking to mentors you
start asking questions you do the
Outreach from people in your industry
and say hey I'm I'm uh I'm a young
professional in this industry I'd love
to pick your brain for 20 minutes I'm
stuck in that kind of career choice
right now
and whatever kind of personal connection
you can make whether it's at the company
maybe there's an alumni from the same
University that you went to maybe it's a
friend of a friend of a friend to line
up as many sessions with with potential
mentors as possible and something good
will happen
um
very helpful I think that happened to me
like so when I sold my business I didn't
know what I wanted to do it was great I
had money awesome but I didn't know what
I wanted to do next and I said yes to a
whole bunch of things and one of them
was a guy who was in Venture Capital who
was part of a firm and I was curious
about raising money didn't I didn't know
how to do it because I never had to
and he brought me under his wing and I I
joined the Venture Capital firm for a
year and a half
learned about all sorts of different
Industries and and that wasn't my
forever thing that was my next thing
that then led to this
and I've been doing this I've been
helping entrepreneurs for wow I don't
know how many years YouTube alone has
just been 12 years
um but that being said like if you if I
stopped liking videos
I would I would just walk away from
YouTube
next
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate I've done that like my website
was the thing that was making me a lot
of money I used to have a I mean my
website was off my name we had a hundred
something thousand pages of content
making money every day I'm advertising
and Partnerships and brand deals and all
that stuff and it's start to feel more
like a job
and um I just didn't like it
and I was really enjoying video making
YouTube so I overnight
shut down my website
put up a picture
to say you know working on it coming
soon
and now you can't find any of that old
content
on the site
and for me it's a much more Vibe thing
like logically it doesn't make any sense
but it ended up it works out because it
when you follow your heart great things
happen now I'm here if I stuck doing the
website I would hate my life
all right I appreciate that I don't want
to take up too much time so um very
helpful I think I am much more logic
driven when I look at like evaluation so
try I I have a lot of art but I tend to
make these type of bigger decisions with
logic so trying to even though you say
follow your art it's a little bit
challenging for me to make that switch
it's the only thing that matters though
for this
like this is the this is the ultimate
skill to learn
for big decisions like this it doesn't
mean like the concern then becomes well
we get too emotional and then I just do
whatever comes into my head and with a
little no you're not you're never going
to be that guy you're never going to be
Reckless
yeah but for big imagine if you're
getting married
you better love her
as opposed to well logically you know
like it makes sense
I think it's probably both of those
right but it better
it better be a lot more on the love than
on the logic
yeah like you see a lot of the guys who
have been married for a while like oh my
gosh I hope he gets this like I'm not
married yet so that's one of the reasons
like this is this isn't this is a skill
set to start to trust your heart which
you need you need both
there are some people who only listen to
the heart and are like doing all sorts
of crazy things and never say consistent
on anything and and never listen to the
Head never stay focused never gets
that's not you you're the opposite yeah
so you need you need to tap into heart
more and it'll make you a more
successful
business person human how you don't like
to focus on how do you tap into the
heart is like I guess the last question
when you feel
something come through you
when you get an idea
your next step is when you get an idea
go do something on it
yeah two percent rule two percent
difference right so when you get an idea
what you will do is automatically start
to plan it and judge it and come up with
Evan's holding up the special Cleveland
Edition
I got that copy as well 2019 tour let's
go yeah that's it like when you get an
idea do something on it and and the good
news is it's all low risk like what
what's your next idea but to to train
yourself that great ideas flow through
you and to take some immediate action on
it this is what I did because I'm much
more logical and strategic
I I was like you and I had to train
myself to do more heart
first
big decisions with your heart because if
you go into your next career or your
next relationship just doing logic first
you're always going to be unhappy
I appreciate it thank you Evan I'll I'll
report back on how that goes oh man keep
us posted Chris in the house what do we
got man so I'm looking at like this
whole like the Fast Five part
um
I'm gonna start reaching out to people
um the amazing content 10 pack
everything else I guess my question is
for the kind of search that I would be
looking for
um you know I'm looking for the 40 plus
mail that is dealing with
um the quote-unquote dad bod issue and
stuff like that and wanting to get
himself in a better shape uh
and then I'm almost probably gonna look
at Instagram because even uh even though
us um people in our later 20s like
myself still go to Facebook uh the I
think most of the people that are
looking for Fitness are on Instagram
everyone [ __ ] about politics on
Facebook I don't got time for that so go
to Instagram to do that right uh what I
mean what kind of search would I use
because it's like my fear would be I
would cold message a guy and say hey
look you know I was just like I felt
your pain trust me uh you know I was 267
270 some odd pounds two blood pressure
pills I was at I was where you were at
uh these are the life changes I made I'd
love to help you I almost feel like I
might insult a guy going were you
calling me fat or something like that no
I'm calling I'm not calling out on any
of this I'm trying to help you
overcomes a challenge at your face cool
yeah so great great question
um the concept from build to serve is
the fast passive Freedom where you're
creating a little bit of content for
your page and then it's mostly based on
Outreach messaging people to offer to
help and it's the fastest way to be able
to grow your business but it's one that
a lot of people don't like to use
because it risks rejection and people
ignoring you or uh not understanding you
and you know a lot of times people don't
like doing kind of the Outreach and the
sales
um for you I would actually look at two
options I would look at Instagram I
think it's smart
um
yeah I think Instagram is going to be
your best bet
okay
um maybe Discord
but really just yeah I would start with
Instagram
uh for your demo and I would look at two
different sets of hashtags okay the
first would be
something where they're like something
like overweight okay like whether where
they're acknowledging so you're not
calling them fat
right they're already self-acknowledging
like overweight dad
especially if you're targeting
apparently overweight might be too big
you can see how much content is coming
in but overweight men overweight dad
and see what they post and and
you'll have some people who are posting
because it's deeply personal to them
because they're struggling they're
frustrated and like why am I so
overweight and and I'm I'm fell back off
the train and like they're they're
sharing their life and they're pouring
their heart and looking for some kind of
support right that's somebody that
you're very empathetic to you're saying
hey I went through this too I'd love to
hop on a call and I've got a couple
strategies I think might work right so
the whole point of the Outreach is to
get them to then check your profile and
you look legit with what you've done and
hop on a call to talk to you about
strategies that then could lead to
coaching or whatever else you're trying
to sell right okay um so that's a much
more empathetic approach because they're
pouring their heart out and they're
probably going to get some comments and
support from their friends but nobody
who can actually help them where you
could actually help
um so yeah you can definitely position
it so that it's not
making fun of them because that's not
what's in your heart you'll also have
the people who are kind of making the
light of it
okay right so whether they're using
hashtag overweight or overweight dads or
even that's where like Dad bod would be
one that you look at
where they're not they're not showing
how they are struggling with it they're
kind of leaning into the humor of it
okay saying look at me haha dad bod you
know like uh here was me at 20 now now
I'm but laughing at it and they're
they're using comedy as uh you know
they're struggling yeah they're just
using comedy right right so for that
person when you're reaching out
you can say hey I saw your post on that
bot like you you lean in on the humor a
little bit more when you say but you
know what if you ever need help
and you want to lose a dad bod
I'd be happy to hop on a call and help
you okay okay unless like you're leaning
into the humor of it unless the empathy
because that's the spirit of the post
that they put up okay my second question
if I may is uh I I the guy that I work
with is my coach after I got certified
to become one has him and I have talked
about
um the conversations going on for a
while about becoming a coach under his
um umbrella but I know he's really busy
with everything he's got going on on his
own stuff so it might be a while before
him and I get to that point and I was
talking with Zan last week and and
there's even mentions in your book too
kind of like do the both hand like you
know you do you and also partner up with
other people my concern is that if I
start my own thing without even him
putting me under him it might ruin a
friendship and a but possible business
relationship is there a way to to just
reach out to me go hey I'm thinking of
branching out at least starting to build
a clientele which will give me the job
experience plus I could work alongside
you but the things I've learned from him
I don't want to like sell off as my own
because well even if there's not a
copyright to it it's just dishonest do
you know what I'm saying yeah
honest conversation yeah okay
that's that's uh
is he in your city can you go see him
face to face or he's across the country
somewhere else lives in North Carolina
and I'm in the sunny Tropical Paradise
of Cleveland Ohio
got it uh simite's happy with the
Cleveland
um yeah that that's a zoom call then
like video
that's not something you handle over
email okay and
what he needs to see is that you're like
he needs to feel your heart and so even
if you kind of stumble on the words and
what you're trying to say okay the fact
that you care about him and what
he has taught you and that you you're
not your intention is not to just steal
his stuff and go do your own thing okay
but you're also looking at like what
kind of relationship this is almost the
same as like you know samit when we
started this conversation up he wants he
wants something more than what he's
getting okay at his at his company and
so in sumit's case it was a no it was
like no we can't do that okay so
ultimately needs to leave and go find
something else you know for him to be
happy like if you see if he's still in
the same spot in five years that's a
problem you know five months okay you
know as long as we're making progress
with five years is a problem for you
maybe there's something new that could
be created like maybe he sees a bigger
spark in you that could lead to a unique
kind of relationship that you're not
just fitting into his typical mold of
what everybody else would be as a
trainer right maybe he wants you to go
and help train his trainers or create
some new division or like you never know
until you bring it up okay
so and I think that has to be done
ideally face to face but again you know
if you're not flying over there but but
Zoom at least so you can see you and and
feel your heart and your even again you
stumble over the words but he
understands better than like just a
well-crafted perfect email that's a
little heartless that could be taken the
wrong way because you inject your own
tone sometimes in a text or an email
that wasn't there from the author yeah I
mean if it's a big deal it may even be
worth flying over there
right I mean how much is a flight to
wherever like it's only eight hour drive
I can drive out there but sure like it's
it's the
um there's two things there it's like
the extra benefit of spending the time
face to face with them but also the
amount of effort that you put in to make
that happen
also speaks about like I really value
this that I would drive eight hours to
come and and see you
right shows how much you actually care
about this and it's not just a throwaway
conversation
coaching
you
know
sounds good thank you
smart asked why mindset matters and so
just you know quick riff I guess on
mindset I think lack of belief is the
world's biggest problem right like
whether you believe you can or you can't
you're right and most people are just
stuck most people feel trapped most
people are around other negative people
who also feel trapped and so you might
occasionally have this idea that great
things are possible but then you fall
back to the negative mindset and
everybody else around you and you stay
stuck
um
I just came back from a
from speaking at two events in in
Phoenix a genius Network and the first
one people paid 25 000 a year to be in
the second one and you pay a hundred
thousand dollars to be in and my uh my
last day I had a morning coffee with a
guy who had sold his business for over
200 million dollars
and now is helping other entrepreneurs
be more efficient and productive in
their businesses and
you know he he picked me up from my
hotel and we drove this house and then
he eventually drove me to the airport
and his house is more like a compound
it's just not it's not just a house it's
like a house and then an entire house
just for his recording studio for he
plays guitar in another house just for
his Taekwondo studio for him to practice
and like four houses in one house and
more than any bit of advice that he gave
me and similar to just being in those
groups it's the the mindset difference
it's like trying to do
life at a bigger level trying to have an
impact at a bigger level and for most of
us we are that source of positivity for
other people we are the ones believing
in other people and pouring into other
people and telling them that they can do
it and giving them love and
encouragement and support but who's
telling us that we can do better and in
a loving way not like you should be
doing this this we got lots of those
people but who's pushing your loving way
forward and for the most part we don't
have those people so that's why I love a
group like this that's why I love groups
like movement makers
um and just in general trying to be
around more optimistic positive people
because sometimes it's hard for Carrie
for us to carry the whole burden of
positivity and optimism for ourselves
and so if you are the most optimistic
person you know that's in your immediate
circle
um that's a problem you know like it's
great that you can don't stop pointing
other people but if you don't have
anybody who's pouring into you then that
keeps us stuck and it keeps us small and
so the mindset shift to feel like hey I
can do more I can be more I can serve
more I can have a bigger impact
um I think becomes really important so
the the whole idea of you are the five
people you surround yourself with really
matters and if you don't know anybody
then get in a group or come back to you
know a group like this
um or even just through content
right that I haven't met Elon Musk yet
but I I get inspired by his videos and
his content and his moves like Elon Musk
is buying Twitter what doesn't he
already have four of the companies that
he's running or something just like it
just makes me question what I'm doing
not in a negative way like I think
comparison actually can be really
beneficial a lot of people say don't
compare yourself to others and I think
people just compare themselves
incorrectly they look at somebody else
and then they kick themselves down say I
can't do it where I like it as a kick
forward say wow look what Elon Musk is
doing I can I should be thinking bigger
and it's an inspiration to go off and do
more otherwise we stay stuck and stay
small
um so anyway that's my little quick Riff
on why mindset matters thank you Samar
for the topic and uh let's let's open it
up Tony's got his hand up what do we got
Tony
I have a personal training and nursing
coaching business for 35 years now and
for 33 years I was doing everything in
person until covet hit switched
everything virtual and online
but for probably the past eight years
since I was about 45-ish years of age
I've been posting non-stop Monday
through Friday on Facebook I've been
emailing Monday
through Friday to me almost I started
doing Instagram maybe a couple years ago
as well I feel lost in that kind of
virtual world so
we went through a great exercise this
morning Movie Makers where I'm I'm
basically I told them that my number two
platform is now Tick Tock we decided
last week that YouTube is number one and
it still is number one by far but I've
switched in the past week from Instagram
to tick tock as number two and so part
of it is being smart with where you're
at because you could you could be
producing the best content ever but if
you're on Facebook like Facebook has
been dead for a long time right there's
no zero organic reach on Facebook it's a
fantastic ad platform but it sucks for
Content
um Instagram
is
slowly not dying but becoming less and
less and less and less and less relevant
it's harder to rank it's harder to win
um we covered a little bit today but the
reels is still going to be your best bet
now like no more pictures it's reels so
I need to see reels I need to see short
form video content
um and then Tick Tock is definitely
picking up steam like we're over half a
million followers on Tick Tock and a
quarter million on on Instagram and
it's taken me like six years to do that
on Instagram in a year and a half or
whatever on Tick Tock and we're barely
taking Tick Tock seriously right like
Instagram's been number one and we just
kind of post whatever to tick tock and
the thing is blowing up
um and it's becoming an education place
as well for people so it's not just
somebody commented like 16 year old
teenagers dancing or whatever they're
still that and there's fun but it's also
becoming an education platform and the
the easiest thing to do is go search for
what you're doing
what you teach and and see what's on
there and you'll see that hey there's
actually education content on there so I
love that you're making content I love
that you're an expert you've been doing
this for so long and you want to serve
um I would look at
if I was getting started now and I
didn't have traction I would do YouTube
long form
and Tick Tock short form but then I
bring to the other platforms
um I would probably completely abandon
Facebook unless it was just easy to post
or you had some kind of community there
already
um and the long-form YouTube videos
would be
not hugely impactful in the short term
but you've been doing this for a while
and you want to keep doing this and so
um
getting whether they're actual workout
videos that you're going to do whether
they're coaching sessions that you have
with clients uh you're imagine someone's
going to see this in a year and two
years and three years and love what
you're doing and sign up YouTube is the
if you want to get off the kind of rat
race you know the hamster wheel whatever
YouTube is it because when you make
content in a year it's still relevant
and valuable and can drive traffic every
other platform is it's insta like
Instagram it's instant it's only what's
happening right right right right right
now doesn't mean that I can't help or
can't convert but Choice a platform in
in choice of content like if you're
doing pictures on Instagram it's just
gone off a cliff
so it's short form video Everybody Wants
short form video now plus long form on
YouTube so I'd look at a if you're not
consistent on YouTube yet I'd look at
once a week making content 10 minutes
plus no upper limit on how long you can
go
and then a daily short form
for tick tock that then you take to the
other platforms
great thank you okay let's move on lady
Lexi what do we got hi there okay
um
today is the Dutch Liberation day 77
years ago there are a number of
festivals they are still going you see
Liberation day yeah Dutch Liberation day
okay great well happy happy Liberation
day yeah so that's my fifth and um which
I think oh no I'm like I need to go to
Rotterdam go to one of those festivals
and make a recording but I'm like okay
what exactly am I going to talk about I
cannot just address all the people there
because I don't have a fresh batch or
anything so how do I make that work
because I feel like it's so important
that we get to speak out and and so I
can either go there or I can do it from
here what what would you suggest what
hold on what are you speaking out again
so it's okay Dutch Independence Day cool
today is 77th anniversary oh that we got
liberated by the English and by the
Americans and there might definitely
even be some Canadian
okay so the idea is hey you need to like
you want to recognize them
haven't was a revolution or was it a you
know like how like they're speaking up
for themselves
it's so important
and I mean especially when with what's
going on in the Ukraine it makes my
heart cry since my my mother is about
speaking up and speaking out this is
about people back then were of course
being uh
delegated basically to to to the to the
camps and put work there and they were
not recognized as people
so it's not necessary that I want to
speak out for what happened there I just
want to you know say like okay let's
celebrate freedom let's remember that
it's important that we do speak up and
speak out
what we what we see and what we find
should change and also on a personal
level
so I mean that could be a great so if
the message is speaking out for Freedom
then that's something that people can
connect with because we want to Target
ideally the world not just
Holland right so most people wouldn't
know that it's dutch Independence Day or
how many however many years it's been or
how Holland even came out of you know
like most people know the story and the
story
Almost Doesn't Matter unless it really
means something to you but if you were
gonna go and make it not just what
happened 77 years ago but where do
people need more freedom right now like
it's a good trigger as a reminder so I'm
Canadian and but like we don't uh we
don't we have we have Canada today but
it's not really that big a deal in
Canada
um but Americans take their independence
day pretty seriously right and so on
July 4th in America if you were to go
off and talk to people about about
freedom
but then make it reflective as to where
do you not have enough freedom in your
life right now
and not just from like the government
imposing something on you but your own
situation like where are you stuck in a
relationship are you stuck in a bad
career are you stuck in bad habits are
you stuck with an addiction like if you
can tie the need for freedom to
something they're facing right now in
their life then it can lead to speaking
up like for yourself if you're in a bad
relationship hey maybe you need to get
out if you're in a bad career maybe now
is the time so you can use this event as
a spark plug to create some change so
you could go if you want to go to the
event you don't need a you don't need a
press badge to talk to people
you just go on the street and you ask
people about what Freedom means to them
but then make it relevant to today I was
like well where do you not have enough
Freedom right now do you think in your
life
and then guiding them to a path of
speaking up
okay uh okay yeah it's going to be a big
step for me you know addressing people
randomly at a festival
um but yeah listen lean in on that
because this is now you speaking up
yeah that's good yeah it's a good
challenge absolutely this is I've never
done it before and this is now you
going after your freedom because you
don't want to be you don't want to have
that blocking mindset anymore
yeah and you may have people who say no
and I want to talk to you no I hate you
I mean whatever you're like speaking
like worst case scenario
um but you'll have some people who will
talk to you
yeah yeah that's nice and then maybe I
can do some shorts some short lives and
then later on make it into a big one and
Coach it on YouTube honestly the biggest
thing the biggest win out of all of this
isn't the content you're going to get
from them it's from you pushing yourself
outside the comfort zone
okay that makes sense the fact that like
one person might say yes to you and
you're so scared to ask people to come
on and then you get one person to do it
even if it's not the greatest
conversation of all time like that
forward momentum and you breaking
through like that should be a video you
should film yourself going
and how scared you are and what whatever
thoughts are in your head
and you're basically speaking up to your
own thoughts to say you know what no I'm
gonna I'm gonna go do this and even if I
if I embarrass myself if nobody talks to
me
I'm still gonna go off and do it I saw a
great clip yesterday on Instagram where
um these these um this guy was a
stutterer
so like he gets nervous and then he
can't talk and and his coach I know you
guys have seen this this coach had him
go out in a busy area and
go up to people and ask them to like hey
can you help me for a second and all he
then would ask him is what time is it
but it took him forever to get it out
because he was so nervous and when he
gets nervous he starts to stutter and so
he's like excuse me
like they're sitting there waiting for
him to like what's going on right now
and eventually he says you know what
time is it and
um he also just shared the story with
them like I must I'm a stutterer and I'm
trying to
be less scared and stutter less as this
is part of my my homework
so even you sharing your story like
that's like the biggest win of all is
you share in your story that where
you're afraid and the mental block
um so that you get your own freedom from
those limiting thoughts too
yeah that's good one so I can just take
my phone I don't need any microphones or
anything right yeah especially if you're
doing two people because if the
microphone's just here then it's harder
to share
and don't worry about the gear just go
do it
okay yeah I'll do thank you I love it
cool good luck that's super exciting
I have two questions I'll put them
together but one of them about Instagram
like I've never used Instagram as a
platform to grow on I was never
interested in growing on Instagram but I
use it as kind of like a resume so that
when people say oh where can I find you
like what can I kind of like you know
like think I'm like oh here's my
Instagram and they can kind of like see
like hey I'm alive I'm active I'm I'm in
the space so I was curious on your
thoughts on that and then the last thing
that I really wanted to ask you is that
uh um I'm in the process of promoting a
book that I that I just uh co-wrote I'm
a collabor and off collaborate and
author and some of the best videos that
I found so far on YouTube on how to
promote a book are from Evan Carmichael
six and seven years ago
any uh thoughts that you had present day
if you were putting out you know I know
you just put out this book two years ago
which is still bringing us a tremendous
value in community and so many things
but if you were putting out a book today
or next month or next quarter uh what
would be some of your I mean obviously
you you have a huge following right so
let's say for someone like me that
doesn't have that well so it's taking
both your questions together you're
you're trying to accomplish two
different things and so if you want to
sell a book then you need to grow your
following
it can't just be a resume
because you need to get people to you
want people to buy your book there's
nothing wrong with just having Instagram
as a resume cool that can that can
definitely work but like what are your
goals for where we want so my goal is to
sell the book cool now well we need to
have an audience
so when you're thinking about something
like a book or product or a course
launch or
um any of these things that we're trying
to we're trying to sell as as experts
there's always your own audience and
then there's other people's audiences
your own audience is the best long-term
most sustainable thing that you can use
and build so you know hopefully there's
not just one book inside Jose Gonzalez
there's more books coming up and so the
more you have an audience the more you
can promote your book
for future ones that come out so now we
need to start building an audience and
so what is your message what is your
content
um that's not going to happen like
instantly right away but we need to
start gearing our minds towards sharing
your message with people so that they
love you and they end up wanting to
support you and also support themselves
by picking up your books Etc
um next more short term for your own
following you could DM everybody on
Instagram with a video asking for
support
so if I really really really really
really really really needed to sell Bill
to Surf like if that was my top priority
I would go through whoever followed me
now we've got you know a quarter million
people on Instagram but if it was two
thousand or a hundred I would I would
video DM everybody
to say hey Faith thank you so much for
following me I want to let you know I've
got a new book it's called built to
serve I'd love your support if if I can
send you a link to check it out
hey lady Lexi thank you so much for
following me like one by one
hand-to-hand combat going off to tell
people what you've got and asking for
their support
and so the bigger audits you have
they're easier that is to do it's not
you know there's only so many you can do
in a day right it's like I couldn't do
that for everybody who follows me but if
I if I was getting started and I wanted
to get my book out or I was launching my
course or whatever that's what I would
do that's why Instagram becomes
important
um we were watching a video this morning
from the CEO of Instagram talking about
Instagram's growth is in direct
messaging and reels
it's not about the pictures it's about
the a lot of a lot happens in the direct
messaging and then in the reels for
Content so use it's my favorite platform
for direct messaging every morning I'm
walking outside and I'm sending videos
to people thanking them for different
things
so that's what I would do as a starting
point with your audience and but it
changes the mindset now it's not just
a resume
that whether it's Instagram or Tick Tock
or YouTube now you you need to build an
audience if you want to sell your books
and anything else
um and then phase two would be also who
else can you
who has an audience that might be
willing to put you on
so one of the biggest things authors
always do when they come up with a new
book is they go in other people's shows
whether it's an Instagram live whether
it's YouTube whether it's tick tock like
wherever they have their audience you
want to try to be a part of it and
hopefully you gain a little bit of
following from them as well so that's
not a sustainable as building up your
own following but whenever you're in
launch mode that's always the two things
like what do I have for my own audience
and and who's who are the other people
who's honest I can tap into to promote
my book
awesome thank you Max good to see you
again cool man I love it we got Tanya in
the house what do we got Tanya
yes hi Evan uh so my question is in
regards of when you are using different
platforms like
um you have your followers all spread
out how is there any way is there any
strategy I don't know to kind of like
direct them to the one that you want to
grow like when I have my personal
account and I have my business account
so in business we have Facebook we have
Tick Tock we have Instagram
uh yes and and we are creating YouTube
after I started moving movement makers I
realized that you know we were missing
that one
yeah then we should have had before but
yeah so we are developing that one so my
idea is kind of like mirror what you are
doing and make a give uh give more
importance to YouTube and then Tick Tock
with which I think is great it's a great
platform I I I haven't paid attention as
much but I like it especially for my
audience and then Instagram but I have
you know I have audience like spread out
is there any way together
I would say
it's not a great strategy to bring it
all together
so you want to meet people where they're
at
some people love Tick Tock and they just
want to stay on Tick Tock so don't try
to get them to Instagram like Instagram
I don't want to use Instagram
some people love YouTube so meet them on
YouTube and if you want to have a big
message then like someone like for me I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem so I got to be I got to be where
the most people are
if you have a if you have a niche
business and it only caters to certain
people then you want to be where those
people are like Tony he was on Facebook
right it's like to say I need everybody
to get over to Facebook
right to do that is crazy because people
are they don't want to use Facebook
anymore
so you meet people where they're at and
help them with what they need help with
and so that might mean having maybe you
can't be on every platform yourself
right now that's okay like you have to
pick YouTube and and one other cool
um but I wouldn't the only thing I would
try to do is capture their email address
so that you have a way to communicate
with them
but I wouldn't try to consolidate them
because a lot of my audience doesn't
want to meet me on Tick Tock or
Instagram and so and and when you do it
doesn't convert very well like when
people come from my take my Instagram to
YouTube they don't watch the videos for
very long
so I actually want them to stay on
Instagram or on Tick Tock or on YouTube
like stay on the platform unless it's
converting to a sale
they're going to hire you for something
or can burn into an email address where
they're gonna
give you their email in exchange for
some bonus that you're going to give
them
okay great beautiful
all right we got we got two minutes
Maria what do we got let's do it
I don't know it might be too much but
we'll do what we can so I I keep
grappling with this for years I have a
niche problem where I have two separate
websites
and I get clients from both and I I so
I'm sort of since I joined movement
makers I I body confidence Solutions and
I know that
the underlying reason that I help people
have sustainable change is I deal with
trauma I deal with stress I deal with
all the stuff that keeps them
you know just recycling back into Old
behaviors and so I have another website
modern stress Solutions which I still
like I was just invited
um on Monday so may is um is mental
health awareness month and I was invited
to do a presentation to 270 construction
workers because the suicide is the
highest industry of suicide
it was so gratifying but the point is
that I'd like I love doing that kind of
stuff around Stress Management around
so like people that look at body
confidence solutions they think well
she's a health coach
I on my I mean I talk about
transformation from the inside out and I
go deeper in my videos about yeah living
in your body and having a more better
connection with your body but that
includes releasing stress trauma
so it feels a lot to have two separate
websites I do two separate newsletters
every week it's sort of crazy
and I don't know if there's a way to I
mean they they are both connected and
they and and you know my story is that I
healed from multiple Eating Disorders
but the stress Solutions is really the
how
you know
so um I don't know I guess my question
is
um
do I like I even notice when I do my
lives on Instagram and people there's
some people that like they really want
to learn some of these techniques even
if they're not struggling with their
weight
so do I I mean do I just keep my Niche
like with you know Health around weight
food and or broaden it I mean I get more
gratification out of
well I guess at all all of it I guess as
long as I'm serving and helping people
to uncover the stuff that's keeping them
stuck that's the piece for me whether
it's weight addictive behavior or
you know depression or any of that
so I think I think it's something a lot
of entrepreneurs will go with to The
Branding and how many brands do I have
and how many websites and how many
accounts it it it is very taxing to have
multiple accounts and multiple domain
names and multiple emails and multiple
Instagrams and multiple tick tocks it
can be very very demanding it's usually
not worth it
um so you have a couple scenarios one
you you leave one that's just more on
autopilot that's there that you're not
actively we're not taking it down but
we're not really doing much with it
because if something comes in cool but
it's not really where we're putting our
Focus or two you combine them into one
and and the one brand is not
not a brand name like body confidence
Solutions the combination is Maria de
Puma
and so everything that I do I'm a
different person to different people for
some people I'm the believe guy for some
people I'm the YouTube guy for some
people I'm the you know the author for
some people I'm the salsa dancer you
know I'll go salsa dancing you know
brought up my studio but some people
don't even know what my business is I'm
just the guy who owns the salsa studio
and it leads to different conversations
but inside everything is still believe
for me your teaching believe through the
books through the content through the
YouTube channel through salsa dancing
through everything is all that's the
Common Thread so that for me is easier
and my my brands have always been a
reflection of me when I first started my
website I did Evan carmichael.com as a
as just as a landing spot like no real
thought behind it and then as SEO became
a thing I wish I called it like why
didn't I call it Small Business
Solutions or something like why didn't
you put some keywords in there and then
I realized no it's actually better
that I kept it off my name because my
name could be whatever I want my name to
be
and so you might find yourself in
another field in a couple years that
still relates to stress and anxiety and
how to overcome those but maybe it's
something completely different that you
realize it's still the same
um so I'm I'm in general it's easier
to build it off of a personal brand as
opposed to a company name that kind of
locks you into a niche so those are your
your three options like one you run all
you run both together and you kind of
will always feel stretched between the
two maybe bring on team and help but uh
you probably won't do either of them
really well
option two is you take one and you
really commit to it and the other one
you just leave on autopilot and when
stuff happens stuff happens cool but
like this is what I'm going to be known
for or option three is you just build
your personal brand and wherever Maria
wants to go that's what Maria ends up
creating and it gives you a lot more
flexibility to do the next thing so I
thought it was the worst decision like
if you go back and ask me when I was 23
years old I thought building it off of
Evan Carmichael first off sounds super
egotistical and also it's like this is
the stupidest thing I could have made
because nobody knows who I am but if I
called it Small Business Solutions or
something it makes more sense but that
ended up being the most genius thing
that I could have done
um and people will connect with your
brand your personal face and your
message more than a company logo
if you want to get a copy
on us
our next training with me to ask your
questions you can go get the book right
there next to me right there I'll see
you there I'll see you to get the book
it's a good one much love